era tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo sono famiglia di oggi siano dati
su hunger games come ogni domenica
rifaccio tutto il cast di hunger games e
questa volta ho inserito un pochettino
di pd youtuber andiamo a presentare
distretti di oggi distretto 1 will smith
e trans a casa distretto 2 super meat
boy è steven universe distretto 3 paolo
bonolis e giulia ben il 34 spiderman e
pietro sono la stessa cosa la stessa
cosa distretto 5 renderman e lo sapri
gamer distretto 6 xavi e ralph
spaccatutto distretto 7 quali j e some
sono tornato col mio cane perché
nell'ultimo all'ultimo episodio che ho
fatto il mio cane siamo morti malamente
quindi almeno abbiamo due tentativi di
vittoria o io ho il mio cane va andiamo
bene distretto 8 sugli esterni distretto
9 jason e jack sparrow distretto 10 fine
jake e ariana grande la prima volta che
metto un personaggio che vale 2
distretto 11 neymar e da lì e alla fine
di spettatori ci vide che procediamo
mentre i tributi stanno sul loro podio
suona il corno stile universe sorprende
ariana grande alla sprovvista e la
uccide peccato che quella non è la foto
di ariana grande si vede vi sono
dimenticato di bb di modifica la prova è
morta quindi se ne frega giuria per la
fugge l'ombra scappa dalla corno glom
brusha de torri corre via il giocatore
saab è rifugiata brigano parigi troina
borraccia piena di altro possa uccidere
le persone con la borraccia vorrei in
testa fa male e ve lo dico
will smith cercherà di dormire per tutto
il giorno step mi spaventa paolo bonolis
il giocatore sabri sconfigge jason in un
combattimento ma risparmia la sua vita
sapri non avrei mai più un'occasione
così per jason fa vj e giulia penna si
dividono per cercare risorse pietro
fugge da spiderman non eravate nello
stesso team suri tende alle ferite this
lander me lo sapevo che ero tra questi
due c'era qualcosa lo sapevo marina
grande è morta che però non è
andiamo avanti ghali tenta di scalare un
albero ma accade alla sua morte alla sua
morte galli e niente i gamer di fa vj
shade sabri cosa ho letto cantano
allegramente quindi shade sapri sono i
miei gamer non lo grande non lo sapevano
giocate sudditi pietro canticchia
tranquillamente jack sparrow lancia sun
nell'addome jack sparrow mi ha ammazzato
il cane io ammazzerò jack sparrow neymar
e jason raccontano storie su se stessi
l'un l'altro ai una volta ammazzato 20
persone io ho fatto 20 gol
spacca tutto muore per un infezione
andiamo avanti ragazzi se si sta
accendendo tutto qua fa vj cade in una
fossa e uova le faccio schifo
cinque colpi di cannone ghali some ralph
tar non se fa vj procedere jack sparrow
lancia un coltello nel petto di pietro
ma jack sparrow a un killer incredibile
sul richiede acceso di ucciderlo rifiuta
ma tenendo vivo sordi ci mancherebbe
altro e altri tutti vivi gli ho un
cadeau e muoio jason uccide super meat
boy con una accetta che è di sconfiggere
slang ma in un combattimento ma
risparmio la sua vita e finisce che
ricevono cibo fresco non sponsor
conosciuto qui sono morti shade super
meat boy wow avevano stato un attimo
generale allora wismith stephen universe
paolo bonolis renderman sabrina sono
ristretti jason jack sparrow catherine
se scuola una freccia al giocatore di
sabri ma manca e uccide invece nei
margini azzurri convince esterni hanno
ucciderlo ma a ucciderlo di nuovo quindi
adesso suri ha convinto tecnica
uccidersi tutti harakiri si fanno
increduli tutti che convincono gente
uccide se uccidi di che io vinco ok ma
ospita colpisce la testa di legame con
una mazza con questo ci ho sempre
pensato io non sono mai riuscito a farlo
ma ho sempre pensato
neymar jason esterni a è anche uomo
snello anche un uomo snello che
effettivamente è vero suri stephen
universe e peeta litigano p.te apita
uccide trionfalmente entrambi jack
sparrow cade in un lago ghiacciato e
annega giulia penna che da paolo bonolis
di ucciderla mantenendovi mantenendo il
rifiuta mantenendo giovane invita quindi
non è morto nessuno sa perché aveva a
dormire pica spinge giulia pelle da una
scogliera durante un combattimento con
un coltello polo colore se si addormenta
e che fini si diceva non accettano uno
sporco
ok procedere vita costruisce una baracca
che ti si interroga la sua sanità
mentale
il giocatore sabri colpisce la testa di
paolo bonolis con una mazza son rimasti
vita katniss e sabrina
incredibile il distretto 12 e rimanenti
tributi iniziano ad avere allucinazioni
il giocatore sabri sopravvive kate
nissan e capita non è vero non sarebbe
mai successo
katniss che ne capite in finale poi dai
no voglio vedere loro due in finale
cavolo se l'è sorrisi che pensarne
capita che pensava fosse uno squalo che
invece cercava di mangiare quindi ok non
lo sapeva poverina ci sarà ma talora
vinto sabri perché lei si sta ammazzando
dal senso di colpa
sabry katniss showdown finale no il
giocatore sabri inconsapevolmente
mangiabarche tossiche ha vinto kate
l'iss ha vinto katniss del distretto
dorici come nel film quale l'unica roba
l'unica roba e che ha vinto ma al senso
di colpa perché ha ucciso pitt a lei ama
vita quindi l'ha ucciso quindi ha vinto
ma era si ammazza nave né un partito né
ha vinto il presidente nessuno perché
tris libra tutta la vita ha un senso di
colpa
mamma mia che finale che è finale da
oscar bellissimo i più belli hunger
games fino adesso in finale incredibile
bellissimo ok ragazzi allora ho
aggiornato la foto di ariana grande che
non era ariana grande primo quindi
procediamo e facciamo la seconda prova
però pronto a morire sono pronto a
morire come sempre vuoi perché mi carico
ricevuto acqua da uno sponsor
sconosciuto spiderman corre via con un
accendino e una corda cosa li servono
che tira è la ragnatela cosa servono
teson fugger è una grande e fugge fine
l'ex fuggono paolo bonolis fugge con un
accendino
neymar trova gli esplosivi vendermi apre
una bottiglia di alcool e uno straccio
umido a fuoco le cose galli e super meat
boy combattono per una borsa gari si
arrende si ritira renderman camuffa se
stesso tra i cespugli sempre lo stesso
sei sempre lo stesso davis o è sempre
rompere va dalla gente mentre sta in
mezzo alla folla è sempre sempre giulia
penna lancia un coltello nel petto di
p.ta
svenderlo in cucina il suo cibo prima di
spegnere il fuoco con cosa lo mangia che
non c'è la bocca ma vj e katniss si
tengono per mano
ho sempre sempre sognato questa cosa
sempre il giocatore di sabri will smith
paolo bonolis attaccano con successo e
uccidono giulia penna la spacca tutto e
stephen universe step non viene
punzecchiato dalle le spine ventre
raccoglie bacche potrebbero essere
bacche velenose esterni forze perse vita
giulia penna ralph e stephen universe
procedere pietro gese un'area da grande
fa vj's lander man dormono a turni ma ma
dov è ma non sarà la grande pietro
imboscano senza successo fa vj figurati
se pietro non mi tirava l'imboscata
rendermene jade e che invece li uccidono
top
siamo sopravvissuti noi il giocatore
sabrine punzecchiatura delle spine forse
cresce ad esprimere lemonia katniss da
non sarà una grande e perché c'è maria
de filippi ma sto gioco cia dei problemi
vabbè lariana grande maria de filippi
prova pietro sono morti né jake non in
grado di cominciare spider man il
giocatore sabri convince fa vj a coccole
con lei facciamo che non linkiamo questo
video ad anima non lo linkiamo non lo
linkiamo questo punto da non linkate
questo video ad anima grazie
procediamo non ho letto niente
procediamo paolo bonolis e riceve
forniture mediche da laurenti su
richiude silenziosamente il collo di
famiglia e quindi su renew ti ammazzo
sempre morto sempre cinque colpi che non
è jason fine j
l'uomo ragno galli e figurati figurati
will smith a vedere una bevanda di super
miccoli lo beve muore ok renderlo in
cucina il cibo prima di spegnere il
fuoco fanno baroni si addormenta il
giocatore sabri canticchia
silenziosamente dove dove erano le
nostre coccole sapere dove e quando
doveva essere difeso la sua ri dove la
cornucopia viene rifornita di cibo come
sempre così verso la fine scorte armi e
memoria di famiglia di tricia del 10 di
non andare su ripar passa
accidentalmente sulla mila e te lo
meriti te lo meriti tecnici di non
andare il giocatore sablici di non
andare renderman singhiozza non ha gli
occhi nel nasone niente mentre stringe
una foto dei suoi amici della sua
famiglia ma non ce li agli amici quello
è quella è una pagina non è una foto
paolo bonolis ticino dalla the fist
jack sparrow come lander me però lui
c'era la famiglia questo hai fatto
procedere sono morti super meat boy e
sul renderman si ferisce attenzione will
smith e tende alle ferite del giocatore
di fabry jade decapita jack sparrow con
una spada strano che scioglie sia più
bravo di jack sparrow a maneggiare le
spade per ok step di uccide shade mentre
cerca di scappare perfetto sono rimasti
o mio dio sono rimasti solo loro e in
quattro sono messi contro renderman step
di giocatore sabri will smith e paolo
bonolis fanno irruzione nel campo this
land airmen però non l'hanno fatto fuori
da qua non solo fatto irruzione ok paolo
bonolis spara un colpo velenoso al
colori step di uccidendo lentamente
lander mette a fuoco weasley da fuoco
alla gente dà fuoco alla gente ora
rimangono svendono in sabrina sempre in
finale paolo bonolis blender ricevano
accetta dallo sponsor sconosciuto il
giocatore sabri ferisce gravemente paolo
bonolis e lascia morire quindi renderman
contro sabrina scontro decisivo dell
melucci nei giocatori e sapri mentre
cerca di scappare ha vinto slider man
from e che poi è ovvio perché in una
foresta non può non vincere slang nome
dice per forza lui e il capo della
foresta ragazzi questi erano gli angresi
oggi vincitori
katniss e islanda non ci credo molto di
più nel secondo spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto è stata una gran battaglia
sabrina in finale due volte con tanto di
coccole vabbè però niente vittoria
devi sapere nei prossimi episodi ci
volete che ci sia come personaggi e come
sempre ragazzi si vede piaciuto commento
mi piace anche la ricerca guido
descrizione siano stabiliti iscrivetevi
abbonatevi noi ci rivediamo
[Musica]